[Music]
there are big ideas and small ideas
ideas come in different shapes and sizes
and I put ideas of some shape or size
and what we live by play as Terry
Eagleton
I'm visiting professor without certain
implicit ideas you know we wouldn't
really have a human life but every now
and then I guess there's a need for sort
of big ideas not least when a society or
a civilization is in kind of crisis it
tends to reach the need to reach out at
four or some people call grand
narratives you know something because we
in a postmodern culture like our own if
you think around say the turn of the
century are 2,000 people have pretty
much given up on big ideas grand
narratives they didn't think they were
needed and the whole climate politically
and culturally was more pragmatic more
modest yeah and then two aircraft
slammed into the World Trade Center and
a whole new grand narrative opened up
really the really the war between the
West and a certain kind of Islam a
certain reading through his mouth which
is likely to dominate history for the
next coming decades I think so whether
we like it or not we're sort of in the
middle of a grand narrative where a lot
of we're in a situation where we're in a
world where some people believe too much
and some people believe too little
people who believe too much I really
kind of fundamentalist at one time or
another whether they're you know Islamic
or or Texan or Western fundamentalist
Christian fundamentalists as a matter in
a sense they believe too much and and
the beliefs of that kind can kill you
know but there are lot of other people
who you might say believe
two little who pretty agnostic about
things you know they just get by we
don't really reflect very much on the
fundamentals the civilization and I
think we're kind of swinging between the
wall and the other you know but whether
we like it or not we're in a period of
big ideas in the sense of a period where
we could be ruining our planet where we
could be preparing for nuclear war you
know all kinds of hideous prospects
faces so we have to think big I think
for that reason I don't think smaller
ideas are really going to work anymore
well I was saying the other day has
taught here that uh that hey let him all
I know about Richard Dawkins is that his
wife used to be in Doctor Who I can't
think of anything else to know about him
I keep forgetting all the rest no
actually but well you see that my
objection people like Dawkins is not to
the fact that he's an ACS but to the
fact that like a lot of atheists he sort
of biases a seeing someone cheap you
actually got a pave your atheism or
agnosticism that's the thing you can't
just reject a kind of crude caricature
of safe Christianity now I think talking
to a lot of other of the new atheist do
they have it they have a sort of view of
Christianity that no intelligent
theologian would accept for a moment or
you can see ology student yeah
and so they make it easy to themselves
you know it's like saying um it's like
saying you know feminism is just about
we've been trying to dominate men so
I'll write it off you know it's a it's a
straw a straw man it's a straw target
just to take one example Richard Dawkins
thinks like most atheists think that the
doctrine of creation
is to do is how the world started and he
think that's kind of nonsense because
he's a scientist a science to tells us
how lost I were in fact Joshua creation
has nothing to do without war started he
doesn't know that but any reasonably
intelligent theologian will tell you
that that's not the case yeah so it's no
point in just travesty ideas and then
just cloning them over it's a pointless
game and I think the Dawkins and some
other some of his colleagues do that not
liquid I mean the problem is that's
because they think theology is nonsense
they don't read it okay so that means
that they don't really in a very basic
sense know what they're talking about
when they're talking theology you know
they're talking about ideas which let's
say no solutions for a century or so has
really taken seriously yeah so yes they
need I mean be an atheist by all means
you know reject the whole lot what's
wrong with me but but know what you're
rejecting and don't just toss ideas
aside in that sort of way there's the
other point about atheism and
Christianity of course our religion is
that religion is becoming an
increasingly central motivation
politically yeah I think of Islam the
opposite one of the problems the West is
that it has sort of ideologically
disarmed at just the point where it
faces a political enemy and the shape of
radical Islam that has some very big and
fundamental ideas yeah and so there's a
kind of imbalance yeah and I think that
the New Atheists rejection of
religion is just so much nonsense he's
actually quite dangerous politically
because it it underestimates the the
living power of religion not always a
powerful good by any means yeah but it's
a real phenomenon you can't just write
it off as a lot of nonsense oh well the
the central message of the Christian
gospel I suppose is that if you love
you'll be killed that's a very nice
comforting this is just me there's your
pie in the sky for you yeah I mean
that's very clear isn't it yeah but if
you love people properly I don't mean
love in the kind of debased erotic
romantic sentimental sense I'm in love
in the New Testament sense and feeding
the hungry and caring for the dying
welcoming the orphans and the widows but
if you do that he's gonna be a threat to
the state and the state will probably do
away with you yeah I read Jesus warns
his comrades was yeah that's what's
gonna happen to them if they took the
same as him so there's no loveliness
about that message of choice very stark
message and I think the New Atheism
avoids that partly because of its
discomfort you know Christianity says
that the world is so warped and so
governed by rather dark powers political
powers that that you can't change that
transform it unless unless you have a
very thorough going transformation of
the self in a society you know what in
that sense Christianity is too radical
understood properly for a lot of people
a lot of good liberal middle ground yeah
who don't really believe that you don't
really think things are that bad
all the first questions you have to ask
somebody I think what are you talking
about any season of Christianity's how
bad do you think it is see and a lot of
people would say that I not that bad you
know there's a lot of progress is true
but I think I think I think Christine
that Christianity believes that things
are fundamentally pretty bad human
history has been a long nightmare of
torture and injustice and bloodshed and
you know and how you're gonna change
that see well whatever could change it
just has to cut very deep yeah and
that's really what Christianity is about
you have to confront the possibility of
death and rebirth say people actually
did live as the gospel teachers yeah
they loved one another they helped each
other and so on though they believe in
justice and then it would transform the
world but I hate there's no question
that if people could live like that that
would be our saving that would be our
salvation the problem is that you know
only a very small number of people are
willing to go through the process of
self dispossession that that would
entail really Christian gospel demands a
self dispossession so radical that the
image of it really is master Justin's
hasn't we prepare to be martyrs and you
know I'm not sure I'm prepared to be a
martyr all you know yeah
I want to go on write in my books and
seeing my children yeah so I mean the
thing is what people like Dawkins to
understand because yeah is an impossible
demand it's rather like Freud thinks of
the super-ego Freud thinks the super-ego
Mission Possible demands on us to be
good and moral an upright and
conscientious and repress our worst
desires and so on the Freud super-ego is
a tyrant now I don't think there are
some kind of versions of Christianity
which model God in that way Steve God is
a tyrant yeah but that's too easy see
because the thing is quite a lot of
people secretly want God to be a tyrant
because they want to be punished and why
do they want to be punished because they
feel guilty yeah and so they want him
they want a real God they want a big
nasty bastard of a God you know who's
gonna wrap them over a knuckles and you
know and they don't want to have a God
who was a fellow sufferer and God who
accepts them in all their messiness so
in other words most ideas of God are
idolatrous those are kind of either like
a super-ego
yeah and it's very hard there for the
tape the Christian message that God
isn't like that at all you know that God
forgives yeah
conviction in martyrdom as it good that
we just misunderstood it's very
dangerous and bad to see Clapton yeah
and certainly as far as I just to go
back to the Christian gospel doesn't
look as though Jesus was seeking
laughter when in fact that before he's
arrested he's panicking badly in the
Garden of Gethsemane sweating blood
doesn't want to die a martyr has to be
someone who doesn't want to die see
because people only who wants to die the
suicide yeah martyrs ensue eyes look
superficially similar but they're not
martyred it's only who gives up what he
or she thinks is the most precious thing
they have their lives for something
which is even more precious in their in
their view unless you really want to
live you can't be a martyr your death
won't be efficacious it won't be
valuable it'll be like a suicide so so
yeah I mean it's a very hard thing
because on the one hand you must not
seek martyrdom on the other hand given
the kind of world we've built for
ourselves people who speak out for
justice or whatever it is you know are
putting themselves in the firing line
and and may become martyrs even though
they don't want
oh well partly to sacrifice is a very
young on sexy concept these days you
know very unglamorous yeah people think
of in terms of giving things up
well yeah but traditionally I'm looking
at sort of some of the ancient ideas of
sacrifice sacrifice is really about the
passage of something of a lowly thing
from weakness to power it's like the
word literally means making sacred and
the sacred for a certain societies is
very powerful and dangerous sacred is
dangerous and to invest something with a
dangerous power is to transform it and
in the Old Testament in the New
Testament what the people who are
dangerous in the poor the poor are
dangerous partly because they've got
nothing to lose people who've got
nothing to lose we're dangerous yeah but
they're also dangerous because they are
they are the people that Yahweh that God
says represents him in the world and
that you will know who God is when you
see the poor coming to power yeah so
sacrifice is about not so much about
giving things up about that transition
for weakness to power I think I mean
it's pretty fashionable today to dislike
the concept of power yeah
and that's because people rather
obviously always think about dominant
power but that's not the only power the
only way you can oppose an oppressive
power is by other parts emancipatory
yeah so I know you power is an excellent
thing you know personally I can't get
enough to excellent depending on who has
it for what purpose is how they use it
you know you can't get away from power
but you can try and use power to undo
various forms of oppression and
exploitation neat ha
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you